[Musique]
bonjour maryse narcisse au bonjour
maurice galle ton et ben on joue aussi à
tous nos édité un qui nous font
l'honneur de nous écouter ce matin dans
un circuit exceptionnel puisque nous
sommes samedi matin et nous tenons
vraiment sur la première à donner la
parole à l'ensemble des candidats et
comme vous êtes 11 donc émission
exceptionnelle
maryse narcisse on a avec georges crayon
vous êtes le des deux candidats
candidats estampillés mine pour cette
élection sénatoriale du 24 septembre
deux candidats sur les onze en lice vous
êtes entrée en lice biais tardivement
officiellement durant la campagne
durant la semaine des inscriptions
officielles en préfecture
c'est une vraie stratégie c'est du
tâtonnement ça un truc qui sort du
chapeau du mincom sur dernier moment non
c'est pas c'est pas du tâtonnement c'est
pas d hésitation tout simplement
il y avait des étapes à franchir et ça
il fallait pas fait autrement
la première étape c'était la validation
de ces candidatures par le comité
national les autres partis de martinique
l'ont fait mais seulement dans d'autres
délais vous savez on était dans une
période de vacances il y avait des
membres qui étaient pour les hôtes warsi
aussi écouter les shaks s'organise comme
il veut on ne gère pas le programme des
vacances ni au planning des vacances la
même manière directe donc il y avait
cette contrainte
il fallait la respecter et le préalable
c'était la validation par le comité
national
ensuite nous sommes dans une majorité
pluie relaté m il fallait aussi informé
cette majorité que
qu'il y avait effectivement ces
candidatures donc ça a été fait
effectuer vous avez raison tout ça a été
fait à la fin pratiquement au début du
mois de septembre puisque vous avez
assisté à la conférence de presse du
président marie jeanne qui s'est tenue
je crois si ma mémoire est bonne c'est
le mercredi avant la clôture des
inscriptions effectuera alors je vais
vous dire une chose résultats cette
candidature elle peut paraître tardive
mais c'est une candidature réfléchie et
organiser parce que elle a fait l'objet
quand même d'une analyse approfondie de
la situation grecque et nous ça parce
que vu de l'extérieur très sincèrement
maryse narcisse aux ça donne
l'impression d'être un petit peu
improvisé tout ça mais nous non pas du
tout josé plusieurs candidats à la
candidature au sein du mime
écoutez cette partie revient aux
présidents marie jeanne je ne sais pas
qui a pas de dire ça ce matin
attendez je voulais bonheur je vous
m'avez posé une question je vous réponds
c'est le président marie jeanne qui qui
a reçu des candidatures
moi je ne suis pas allé lui demander qui
a fait acte de candidature pas du tout
parce que nous a dit jeudi très
officiellement micro il n'y a eu que
deux candidatures et qui assemble à dire
le tennisman guy st mais voilà donc ça
c'est à ce niveau c'est à lui de
répondre à cette question c'est lui
c'est à lui que revenait effectivement
cette décision donc vous comprenez bien
que je n'étais pas rentré de faire le
marchandage qui est rude à kinect mais
ça c'est une chose mais je dis que le
plus important et on peut s'effectuer
cette candidature peut paraître tardive
je vous le concède mais il fallait
respecter ces étapes et ça j'y tenais et
je le dis d'ailleurs même temps que ces
étapes n'était pas franchie parce que
l'autre circulait depuis déjà certaines
oui voilà vous savez ce sont des rumeurs
tant que les jeux ne sont pas officiels
ce sont des veaux muret puis à des
commentaires
personnellement je ne suis pas un
commentateur de commentaires donc et je
suis clair là dessus tant que les étapes
fondamentales n'était pas franchie il
n'était pas question pour moi de
m'engager dans cette manche alors avec
georges qu'ayant qu'on recevra en milieu
de semaine prochaine
vous avez été présentés comme étant des
exemples de loyauté de fidélité
d'implication pour alfred marie jeanne
est-ce que ça c'est un gage pour votre
réussite au soir du 24 septembre
je crois que lorsqu'on s'engage dans ce
type
de fonctions électives la loyauté la
régularité la fidélité effectivement
sont des gages de confiance parce que
nous allons solliciter nous allons
souhaité les suffrages des électeurs
il faut qu'il y ait une base de
confiance donc celui qui nous a mandatés
celui qui nous a missionné a
effectivement révélé les éléments sur
lesquels il s'est appuyé donc parler les
facettes de revers de la main comme ça
d'autres qui auraient pu avoir d'autres
ambitions ça devienne pas du tout il n'y
a pas le voir comme ça je le dis toi que
je te ferai faut pas le voir comme ça et
je vous assure je les dis je le dit
partout que ce soit au sein d'une ligne
que ce soit au sein de la majorité
plurielle de la ctn il n'y a pas pénurie
d'hommes compétents
il n'y a pas pénurie d'hommes compétents
ni d'hommes de bonne volonté
simplement aujourd'hui effectivement
pour cette mission begeorgi clairement
nous avons été missionné pour ça pour
d'autres missions d'autres camarades du
parti ou de la majorité seront missionné
je les mets en aucun cas réquisitionné
réquisitionné c'est au terme trop
pompeux ouais je n'en veux pas me gêne
de révoquer large sourire pour ce qu'il
a pour ceux qui nous écoutent radio vous
arrive sur grand soir explique énoncé ya
forcément quelque chose que ce soit toi
je vous ai posé la question oui parce
que vous savez quand vous le dit on
on pourrait penser mais qu'on fait
l'unanimité puis que comptent-ils unique
non c'est pas ça du tout je crois que
nous sommes dans une mission il faut le
rappeler aujourd'hui le peuple nous a
confié un mandat il ya une mission et
dans cette continuité
nous devons assumer et ce sens et 60 de
l'engagement gym animaux jouent d'alfred
marie jeanne a bien répété lorsque vous
a présenté officiellement georges client
et vous il a présenté son programme pour
la martinique
à l'occasion de ces élections de
de la collectivité territoriale de
martinique en décembre 2015 que son
programme est loin d'être achevée et que
la présence d'hommes et de femmes au
sein des instances gouvernementales
ça fait partie du processus absolument
il faut aujourd'hui et c'est l'intérêt
de ces élections et c'est le fruit de la
démarche que nous cherchons à initier
quand nous rencontrons les élus locaux
aujourd'hui les collectivités locales
sont menacés là le sénat est par
excellence la chambre de représentation
des élus locaux
et quand je dis menacés parce que les
orientations qui sont prises par le
nouveau gouvernement
cette fois apparaître certaines
opportunités mais vous avez des menaces
qui sont là quelques saisons par exemple
pour les collectivités territoriales
quelles sont les menaces que vous
semblez percevoir au niveau du
gouvernement de monsieur macron mais
lorsque monsieur marc du président
d'ordre du président et de son premier
ministre
tout à fait lorsque le poids le plus
violent et le premier ministre dise
qu'il faut favoriser une déconcentration
des services de l'état au détriment de
la décentralisation c'est le pouvoir des
élus locaux qui quelque part mis en
danger
c'est les élus locaux qui qui sont face
au risque d'être bâillonnés au profit
des hauts fonctionnaires des communes de
l'est dd je dirais des hauts
fonctionnaires de l'état qu'il faut le
peuple est d'accord avec la démarche
puisqu'il en est lui très
majoritairement monsieur macro mais le
peuple a élu monsieur minc ou mais
monsieur lafon au bout du afin de
dévoiler son sa politique et c'est cette
politique là qui jusque d'être de mettre
à mal je demande aux élus locaux
donc sur ce point je dis qu'il n'est pas
question que nous laissions justement
cette décentralisation pour laquelle les
élus locaux à travers la loi de mars 81
qui a porté sur la réforme de la
décentralisation il pour lequel le sénat
a lourdement contribué
et bien que ces efforts soient mis à
contribution je vous rappelle moto que
dans ce cadre là dans la réforme de la
décentralisation
cette réforme a suscité énormément
d'initiatives au plan local notamment le
principe et le contenu de la libre
administration des collectivités locales
le
le les compétences et les ressources
l'autonomie de recrutement des
personnels territoriaux et j'en parle
c'est sûr cela est venu s'ajouter cette
fameuse collectivités territoriales de
martinique d'optique qu'il faut
quiconque il qu'il faut peut être
améliorée qui est encore avec ça qu'il
faut l'améliorer ce mail est solide mais
absolument et c'est là où j'ai nous
disons sur yale point par exemple maryse
narcisse opus que vous vous en faites
partie
ça fait parti qu'est ce qui ne
fonctionne pas mais déjà le peuple vous
regarde vous économisez temps il ya
énormément de points vous savez
aujourd'hui vous regardez les
les conseillers exécutifs par exemple
lorsqu'il démission de l'exécutif
ils ne peuvent pas revenu dans
l'assemblée alors que le peuple aura
confié un mandat sur une durée mais ça
c'est déjà un point de service vous avez
vous allez présenter tout de suite une
fois que je vais soutenir le prix de la
septième de cette démarche
il y a aussi cette fluidité cette
passerelle qui doit exister entre les
deux structures pour que dans les délais
de transmission dérapant aimé qu'il y
encore des personnalités aux
personnalités que nous avons en ce
moment j'ai toute la journée chez alfred
marie jeanne
il ne faut pas mettre en accusation les
hommes c'est le chauffeur en question je
vous réponds et avec honnêteté ne
mettons pas en accusation les hommes
regardent ont justement le système
comand il est fait comme il est bâti et
prenons au mot justement le gouvernement
quand il dit qu'il faut réduire la
prolifération législatives il faut
donner plus de temps aux contrôles il
faut donner plus de temps à l'évaluation
et bien justement dans sa nous disons
que le contrôle de l'application du
doigt les textes d'application justement
qui servent danalyse de des modalités de
mise en oeuvre de ces lois qui nous
régissent
il faut regarder les insuffisances vous
avez parlé également de la baisse des
dotations de l'état aux collectivités
oui c'est une menace
pourquoi
parce que aujourd'hui le gouvernement
dans sa politique de réduction des
déficits budgétaires
c'est 300 millions de baisses de
dotations pour les collectivités et ses
300 millions pourquoi sa porte sur la
politique de la ville vous avez une
baisse des crédits de la politique de la
doc c'est l'aide aux quartiers
défavorisés qui menacerait et vous avez
pratiquement une enveloppe de 40
millions dans ses 300 millions et puis
vous avez aussi la baisse des crédits
chez l'aménagement du territoire et une
enveloppe emploi de 36 millions est le
plus gros c'est cette enveloppe de 216
millions qui porte sur quoi et bien sûr
les deux passions d'équipement des
territoires ruraux et sur le fonds de
soutien à l'investissement local
c'est carrément et je le dis aux élus
locaux c'est carrément le
l'investissement le soutien à
l'investissement des communes de moins
de trente mille habitants maurizio
lorsque vous isolez fois d'offenser la
montre combien nos communes à toutes les
deux qu'il de tomber donc c'est 98 % des
communes de la martinique qui sont
menacés par cette bête de dassault et je
poursuis à côté de ça vous avez la taxe
d'habitation la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation qui porte sur 80 % des
ménages
il faut rappeler il faut rappeler qu en
martinique
la taxe d'habitation représentent 100
millions d'euros par an ouais donc ce
n'est pas rien et lorsque vous savez que
les collectivités locales ont déjà fait
des efforts depuis 2013
doc c'est des baisses de notation qui
aujourd'hui mme nadeau ghorab y compris
d'autonomie financière à votre cheval de
bataille maryse narcisse au les grands
électeurs le perçoivent comme ans
lorsque vous les rencontrez ce qu'ils
sont très sensibles à cette démarche et
ils sont sensibles à tout le reste ou
non il faut que cette année il adresse
des satisfécits à tous les candidats non
faut pas mépriser le vote des
cochonneries cela il faut il faut
respecter cela qui se succèdent ici
disent qu'ils ont reçu un bon accueil au
sein des conseils mais c'est normal
c'est normal c'est normal et et nous
remercions justement ces conseils
municipaux ses collègues qui nous reçoit
mathématiquement à ce que lundi l'onu
par le mime peut être désigné sénateurs
le 24 décembre ce qui là aussi cette
logique arithmétique qui n'est pas
favorable
les élections forcément remis les
élections c'est pas un calcul
arithmétique si c'est elle quand le sort
est aujourd'hui et il faut pas non plus
stigmatiser
l'umih les élus du mime sont des élus
qui sont convaincus de défendre la cause
des martiniquais et aujourd'hui le
parlementarisme que nous proposons c'est
un parlementarisme au service des
collectivités par sa vie des partis
politiques pensé à vis de clans l'oxer
nous sommes dans une démarche pour
défendre les intérêts des collectivités
très bien lequel il ne reste qu être
second plus personnellement marie sedan
6 o lorsque vous êtes candidat aux
sénatoriales
cette année est ce que ça veut dire que
vous laisser le champ libre à aurélie
n'est là pour les municipales en 2020 à
ducos faut pas prendre comment dirais-je
cette démarche comme ça parce que nous
sommes et lunel et moi nous sommes dans
le même parti et nous sommes membres de
ce parti
nous avons tous le même travail à faire
pour le parti aujourd'hui il est
qu'elles sont des sénatoriales
parce que nous sommes des élus du mime
et comme les autres aux commandes de la
ctm
je vous ai dit que le sénat et par
vocation par excellence la chambre de
représentation des élus locaux en 2007
au loup en europe heures doit voilà nous
sommes pas dans ce schéma nous parlons
des sénatoriales au jeu merci beaucoup
marius narcisse au candidat soutenu par
le mouvement indépendantiste
martiniquais pour les sénatoriales de
2000 les sénatoriales du 25 septembre
une journée
[Musique]
extraits